Journal note to self dear reader fall of
the North Star
erratic reminiscent of Starlight sins
uniform rooftops within the five block
radius
adjusting our lens further down into the
scope of an urban city outlines of
humans mechanized by social structures
disappearing to a hole in the ground and
are erased calibrating the audio reveals
decompressing diesel brakes trudging up
the upper west side car engines idling
even louder but Pizza selling the times
across from the bodega
location only matters because of
conditions that create location
we discourse in dualism operating under
the assumption conditions run parallel
that space entry relates through distant
memory Langston and gwyndolin nerulo and
Murray home hear the echo on the
overground railroad part metaphor apart
homage to Harriet who would have freed
more if they'd known they were in
bondage
perhaps we can be New Millennium Harris
create Renegade languages rescue and
Status Quo from language bondage as in
them Shackled and don't even know it
traveling through black spat night
snaking around corners into new corners
refusing a final destination
tending to see through the train
synthetic glass plane
125th Street in Block lettering America
appears over the left breastplate of a
man in solid blue dress
uniformity along the aisles everybody
facing north as if something unknown
awaits Amazing Grace the Homeland man
the homeless man in the corner with his
handcuffed for change belts
How Sweet the Sound no one hears only
the Drone
because Hulk doesn't exist 2009 Harlem
New York
answer the phone at 10 pm
of the reserve hello in Annapolis night
filled with Palace snow and Harlem
respond with okay
listen be attentive when you learn he
died in the hill of gunfire the
intersection of Minnesota Avenue and
East Capitol streets in the nation's
capital after thinking that's [ __ ] up
think your old college roommate for
calling
ignore that he greeted you as hook the
nickname you went by in the streets hang
up you can and can't believe the truth
simultaneously right d-i-s-c-o in your
leather journal maybe this will
immortalize the image you would never
forget him but you've already forgotten
hook
but for the before the black birds Echo
bangs against your window seal wake up
go directly to the mahogany desk between
two windows sit in the brown swivel
chair stare at the building opposite
your building
rearrange papers that don't need
rearranging twice
open your journal to the name written
last night
Disco
remember
Detention Center five hours after that
release disco willing and ATM through
your basement on a hand cart out of the
wall with metal chain and pick up truck
here pool the money machine
did that this is your introduction
turn on the computer type Theodore
Blandford in the search box click the
magnifying glass expect to be surprised
even though you know what the results
will bring don't be surprised when you
scroll to Maryland double homicide
suspect shot kill in DC
one lone bird outside your window flies
backwards that indeterminate rate of
speed while the world moves forward
the bird is red
look for balance in the Oddity
note that double homicide is five
syllables
five deliberate pause is before damn
remember you knew the suspect shoot a
killer
suspended Court in your imagination and
for indeterminate words to formulate the
phrase whole Court in the streets
this is how he would die
holding Court in the streets prophetic
after reading that the now deceased wife
had wanted a divorce this Deuce it was
because of drugs visualize the wife and
sister just before death in their double
wide try to make sense of the blood
spilled on the carpet the red is
deafening screen
wait for the buzz to stop buzzing
because someone rang the wrong buzzer
there is always an echo after the
buzzing even after the buzzers again
don't answer it it's not for you
keep reading the online article but more
specifically the phrases forcible entry
in protective order
acknowledge that your friend was a
suspect and his first wife's murder too
a dead body in the trunk
two days later while driving to school
to teach call short man because it takes
that long to find someone to talk about
traffic
tell short man who is the barber and has
10 years of Razor tucked behind his
memory what happened
agree in unison that prison would turn
the brain into a hum agreeing again that
prison taught you to be a better
Criminal though you both digress
both of you understand the term anomaly
but it meant that this school was a
positive many men who never learned to
be a man
you would then ask the question for the
first time
why
return back home from New Haven before
rush hour begins to bottleneck the Cross
County Parkway dig through the closet
for the first version of your memoir
disco roll is safe out of the department
store the first line of the paragraph
read go to the next page where he loves
to pull the trigger of a gun more than
the Torso of a woman flip to the page
where he and his sister distributed LED
bullets through the wind windshield and
the impressions of circular holes when
the discarding lead pierces the glass of
Swift
pronounced
the body
is a question mark
he tried to run over the wife with his
truck and then threatening her with a
claw handle she told the police
ask yourself why this sign didn't
signify violence
what theory with Ferdinand this is
classified this under
put the manuscript back in the closet
don't beat yourself up because you knew
he was a killer and said nothing to
nobody
forget the double negative your mom
would correct you on
and tell yourself as Nation versus
nurture
justify your silence in saying that the
world you once lived in was filled with
silence and Mayhem
that is why they called you hook
don't block Audrey Lords your silence
will not protect you from your mind
Pretend This is penance
wake up the next morning
go back to the computer
press any key to erase the black screen
ignore the black birds outside your
window while telling yourself this is
the last time
you need to forget
but before you do one more search
click inmate violin death in the news
a flood of black birds appear suspended
in animation at the top right corner of
the web page ignore them but then don't
tell yourself this is not common Edgar
Allan Poe Style
he did not want her to leave
she wanted him to go
said he needed treatment
think back to the 12-step literature
that cautions about the 13th Step
sexual fraternization with people inside
the circle
feel confident in assuming that she was
a recovering addict
and understood addictive behavior
two addicts don't make it right
tell yourself this
read about the interaction with police
who failed to notice the inevitable
admit the judicial system is failing to
protect women
I am victim was tattooed on the forehead
yes she remained invisible to the
Patriarchs the ones who want to protect
and serve ask yourself does his death
matter more than the victim's death
convince yourself that race never stops
running their memory will eat your ass
alive
say I am a changed man but no one will
heal you
get back in the bed
put the covers over your face remember
the dream
forget hook
wake up tomorrow
and feel guilty again
and so that was a piece I read from my
first Memoir it's called hook
um and it's really we talked about
incarceration of women which is
um the most invisible within what I call
the inside
um I don't necessarily subscribe to
the notion of prison or ex-felting a
conduct I don't necessarily believe in
that [ __ ] uh as language
because I'm not an X to anything I'm not
a felon I'm just me
you know what I mean
um
so I think it's interesting sometimes
however I do get it when I'm in places
like this I have to think of you know I
understand
the things that I have to if I'm about
to work I have to be putting myself on
the split a little bit
so I had some negotiation
but it's my negotiation and I determine
the terms it wouldn't happen you know
what I'm saying so there's that too
um but this is um a book it's an
epistolary so it's but it's basically
half meat half a woman that was
incarcerated named l in Brooklyn
Detention Center at the feds and she was
she was the since detained for three
years in the federal system
um and we and we share letters back and
forth so this was actually my first
Memoir and then a lot of the things that
I kind of did in my life come to her in
mail call so you actually read through
her eyes and the the main reason I did
this was because of the silence and the
absence of women voices in this whole
thing that we do excuse me
um
yeah I mean we just heard that right
so it's not a it's not a it's not it's
not a hyperbole in that you know go to
these spaces
the least represented at all times so I
think you know as I am an author but I'm
not
vain enough not to understand like my
Mish what I'm doing with this language
is to sort of like give people's voices
too so she's part of my Memoir with that
right there so I'm gonna read you a
little bit from um dead weight which is
my new one
um and it's basically starts off with
the conversation with Ralph Ellison's
Invisible Man
on Riverside in New York and basically
I'm talking to the protagonist because
um I'm going ripping off John [ __ ] why
I'm gonna say it's you know amount of
characters somebody says melodrama and
so what I I like to think about this
whole thing sometimes is how we become
protagonists
in somebody else's melodrama and so I'm
thinking about the Invisible Man and the
protagonist and how our lives intersect
in very interesting and weird ways
you know what I mean through time as
black men right
so there's that but it's a long it's
long meditation so what I'm going to do
is going to read you the beginning of it
and then I'm going to flip to a section
that sort of like gets at the heart of
where I grew up which is Alabama and
Birmingham uh place which I really love
in all these complications I love that
place because it's my home first of all
but second of all I like I like it
because people keep it real
you know who you messing with up here
somebody can be so just because
the n-word doesn't live there's an eagle
don't hear doesn't mean it doesn't live
in the imagination the people walking
down the streets coming up before you
man and I feel like I find it very
interesting that people fail to
recognize that one single thing
anyway
the protagonist and somebody else's
melodrama
the Ephraim will foliage to my left
blocking the picturesque view from
Riverside is outlined by hemp dog Bane
hey scented Ferns and golden Alexanders
before the Riverbanks Edge Virginia
bluebells frankly obscure the yellow
Water Taxi sputtering southbound toward
that section of lower Manhattan
resembling an upside down middle finger
burning the Hudson on the New York City
map
100 yards out over the river seagulls
pipe unpredictable trajectories and
broken syntax often suspending
themselves mid-sentence waiting in the
deaths of Surah then Free Falling Back
was into patterns of descriptive sign
language
two BMX riders with black bikes parallel
and identical and pedal rotation rapidly
approached before scuttling Southbound
on the walkway to a muted blur unaware
of the subtext of uniformity
at 139th vintage flood lights do not lit
are pronounced erect and line single
file along the walkway
a mother haphazardly weighs the wander
streaming bubbles White Horse trailing
son and daughter play a game of catching
versus the bubble long before the game
of life's burst the innocuous State and
reality smashes into them head on with
the force of a Mack truck
there is Serene music in the background
allow congregation offenses invisible
within the trees their combination
culminating voices singing in purple
Coral structures
diesel engine buses join the melodious
overtone with the Stop and Go of their
compression brakes up and down Riverside
because it is mandated by the New York
City Parks Department to clean up after
your dog they're up sporadic flashes or
pooper scoopers bending down where
plastic bags should retrieve animal
waste deposited on the walkway
a few more steps up the Steep incline is
145th Street and the official entrance
to the riverbank State Parkway is tall
perforated metal sign bearing the Park's
name in bright red letters accented by
the wrought iron gate painted green
complete with the guard shack nearby
then the view to the left ends back to
the brackish Blue Water of the Hudson
before opening onto a canopy of trees
as if the appending stretch of walkways
to calm before the storm
dust seems more than equal to descend on
this east coast island and headlights
will soon stabbed the darkness while
inching across the bridge into New
Jersey
the smell of yesterday's rain is Crystal
in hell with each elongated stride
along the walkway
at 150th Street a small over-shaped park
has at its Center a 15 foot high
10 foot wide cinches thick bronze
sculpture by Elizabeth Catlett resting
on a raised bed of grass
carved out of the slab as a silhouette
of a man who has no rib cage or fleshed
or veins his insides are cut out
the silhouette holds his right hand up
as if to say stop
while the left is anchored to the side
as the providing balance against the
turbulence the world is capable of
inflicting
a sort of rudder
next to the monument is the concrete
marker inscribed with these words
ah
I am an invisible man
I am invisible
understand simply because people refuse
to see me
behold
Ralph Ellison's Invisible Man
the silhouette whom I should call cut
out man could represent me in vary
stages of a complicated life at times
unescape unable to escape the social
pitfalls that have been followed in the
school of black men particularly in the
80s in error that seems so damn my kid
now
the residual damage caused by drugs and
lungs prison sentences however is ever
presence
present I take a seat on one of the
curved benches nearby and study My
Doppelganger in amazement as spectator
and spectacle fanatical light thinking
how easily the sculpted of this Timeless
character in somebody else's melodrama
sequestered an unimaginable protagonist
rendered real
the unauthorized biography of ours Yes
mine and his life trajectory charted a
path rocked with racism deception
trickery willful ambiguity satire
and committed relief alongside the
theater of the Absurd
we were only made aware of our line of
society through an accidental point of
view
that moment we were able to reverse the
lens and peer into Twisted eyes
connected to a brain that dream a
horrific fantasy for which this seems no
immediate Escape
cut out man and I fell victim to a nav
that featured us as the tragedy the Sad
Sack the bumbling idiot unable to
control the Thematic threats within our
own storyline
we could not hear the hidden or silent
dialogue that kept our daily existence
simmering below the surface of the
living
the only difference between us is that I
was born out of the pen but of the flesh
blood courses through my veins and I'm
filled with bonus and new yet my insides
too
are invisible as a cutout
I get up from my bench and position
myself so that I am looking into cut out
Man's eyes before he can split the scene
on this day we are alone in New York
City
Hamilton Heights to be exact a rarity in
the city of millions I have long held a
burning desire to dialogue with this
symbol of Erasure about the madness that
made both of us real
this is my opportunity
although I'm talking to myself I am
talking to cut out man today he will be
my therapist I can see straight through
his body
clear across the Hudson to the Jersey
Shoreline
he is a pattern or a figure traced and
cut from a human being
an outline within an outline
let me switch a little bit to one of the
sections
um
okay so I'm actually I'm basically so
which what other part is you're going to
catch me talking to him in mid in mid in
mid conversation because it's really
long but I wanted to get this one in and
it deals with the situation around James
Baldwin's um that moment when you
realize that we ain't all this in all
this together
[Music]
um
so here we go although Brown and Board
of Education was decided in 1954 so I'm
talking to him now right we're going
through this whole dialogue some schools
and districts waited until the early
1972 sit to desegregate in Birmingham
Alabama or that Magic City that glowing
Republic of Southern oligarchery
compliance came with the waning islands
in the fall of 72. this desegregation
included integrating teachers which
brought me the 10 year old to the
emphatic statement about white people
my mother and I entered God in their
Elementary as a social experiment of
integration mandated by the court and I
will soon come to find out what it meant
to be black there is a wonderful video
of James Baldwin debating William F
Buckley at Cambridge on the argument
that the American dream has been
achieved at the expense of the American
Negril
the event was hosted by the Cambridge
Union a student debating Society in
1965. four years after my birth at the
segregated South Highlands infamous
infirmary in south side
there is a moment about 18 minutes into
the video and some of you may have seen
this with Baldwin articulates
in the case of the American Negro born
in that glittering Republic and in the
moment you were born since you don't
know any better every stick and stone
and every face is white
and since you have not yet seen a mirror
you suppose that you are too
it comes as a great shock around the age
of five or six or seven to discover that
the flag to which you have pledged
Allegiance along with everybody else is
not a pledge allegiance to you
it comes as a great shock to discover
that as Gary Cooper is killing off the
Indians and you're rooting for Gary
Cooper
that the Indians were you
the thing is cut out man before my entry
into Gardendale every time I pledge
allegiance in the classroom it had been
with kids who looked like me kids that
learned the high five dap up and shoot
marbles between shotgun houses with as
we would Meandering into our teenage
years
did you know that Tony Morrison took the
position that something was launched in
segregation
the loss doesn't celebrate the division
of racism produced but what came out of
that division
a way of going against the grain for the
sake of self-survival taking the
Blackness forced upon you the [ __ ] that
you became and making it valuable
something to be studied imitated
appropriated and commodified within
contemporary culture for the sake of
Modern Art
me and the kids I once pledged
Allegiance with were being conditioned
to blindly pledge loyally to a system we
hadn't begun to understand nor had that
system pledge allegiance to us
there had been Dynamite blasts water
hose is thrust upon the throngs billy
club beatings dog bites hangings
insurrections Against Humanity and
violence right in our own City and yet
we remain oblivious to our outer world
of segregation encapsulated in our own
Society of perceived otherness
maybe if we kids have been aware or if
our parents had been more awoke we all
were revolted against this narrative or
at least questioned this insane
allegiance to society not yet fully
committed to our best entrance
and yes
I would watch the old westerns with my
father
cheering for the Cowboys to do the
Indians dirty
even outside playing with my friends
between the shotgun houses in Smithfield
I shredded a six shooter cap gun full
with cowboy suit thinking I could be the
Lone Ranger when in actuality all I
could ever hope to be was Tonto
a sidekick
we're Baldwin knew and I didn't but will
soon come to find out was that there's a
terrifying moment within one system of
reality a moment that would
contextualized race from which there is
no return
true
you do become the thing to be hunted and
treated like an animal the trauma is
difficult to repel and remember
I begin slow
meek
then it happened
say what I can't hear you speak a little
louder
cut our man is pushing the story out of
my mouth don't hold back now get it out
speak
I come back again with then it happened
that's it now we talking I continue with
authority the ball was up in the air and
Michael Hallmark my new miss my new best
white friend had thrown the spiral
perfectly and I was so fast I thought I
would jump high out of my PF Flyers and
then they release real type I wanted to
jump high but couldn't jump high enough
because the ball was selling too far
from my fingertips to reach it the ball
hit a girl on her side I picked the ball
up she kicked real hard call me [ __ ]
call me [ __ ] call me a [ __ ]
and I punched in her mouth with my fist
hard red appeared on her face
red blood rolling down her white face
she started crying I started laughing I
wanted to cry
she called me a [ __ ] and I hit her
real hard
and it felt damn good
let me be clear
Eunice Pearl Davis now Horton but
daughter to Rosalie was never timeout to
stand in the corner type mother
my mother never hesitated to give
teachers full authorization to paddle
without parental consent when deemed
necessary
I have no memory of how I arrived at the
principal's office to wait for
punishment maybe it was the ear in
silence surrounding the event because
the teachers knew something I did not in
terms of the history related to black
boys
and white women in the south
the memory of what transpired after my
arrival is clear Eunice pearls comes
into the office and says to the
principal standing over me do not lay
one hand on him
now when I say never
I mean never ever the Eunice Pearl under
those words in regard to punishment
I knew then in this racialized moment my
response to an action was bigger than
the ACT
but Baldwin knew that there would come a
time
in that time had arrived
it would take a few orbits around the
Sun for me to understand the enormous
weight the intensity of the Primal scene
that could have taken my life
forget two years after 11th grade day
segregation from my mother but then
don't
how on September 15 1963 a Sunday
morning Dynamite blast inside of church
more four little girls into a forever
memory
forget Carol Denise McNair but don't
forget Adam and Collins but don't
forget Cynthia Wesley but but don't
forget Carol Robinson but don't
and don't forget black boys
there's always a lineage of black boys
to draw context from too
they had been very aware of sitting on
the handlebars of his brother's bicycle
who caught a bullet in the chest from a
shooter riding shotgun on the back of a
Confederate flag bearing motorbike the
end result face down in the ditch
James Robinson angered by the church
bombing because he had already
experienced a moment of race realization
gunned down two hours after the blast in
an alley and make no mistake the police
account matters more than the victim
the usual responses came after the fact
he launched reached looked suspicious
made a move they always flee the police
fired in the air fighting self-defense
because [ __ ] be magical [ __ ] hang
themselves by themselves turned water
into wine slip out of handcuffs be
looking like every other [ __ ] do other
[ __ ] time in jail real and imagine
make Freedom disappear in the finger
snap
or turn it into a life sentence
or worse yet
[ __ ] get shot dead
and the world changes the television
Channel unbothered
unfettered in a move
my father who left work with the ghost
of Emmett Till on his mind when he got
the car from Gardendale Lutheran
elementary that I had hit a white girl
with years later admit
he had to go
had to
he had to because I was in a place that
didn't want me that said hey [ __ ] every
day to discourage me from falling in
love with their idea of beauty their
idea of Truth to never mistake Blackness
for whiteness in terms of privilege the
principal wanted integration was part of
a movement in Birmingham for equal
education and access perhaps was a dream
in believing that all men and women were
created equal
in his dream he saw the need to protect
this little black boy from a fate all
too clear for black boys who didn't stay
in line
the parents wanted blood or neck and
we're not at all happy that little girl
was blood coagulating on her face and
lips got clocked in the mouth by a [ __ ]
but neither was the black boy happy and
being called a [ __ ] so we sat in the
conundrum
in the end
the principal sided with his gut the
question being what I had done wrong
what had I done wrong
my parents taught me not to hate
I did not call the girl trailer trash or
any other derogatory terms I would come
to know as an adult
perhaps the principal had no choice if
this social experiment was going to have
the opportunity to work
but what about the below the surface
narrative by those who often control the
narrative whispering in the parents ear
you know he can go missing
didn't happen before
turn up
in the Coosa River with his face eaten
by catfish
I would never know how close I came to
being seen as Sun up with my next snap
to Keller Ingram Park hanging from a
makeshift wooden cross
I would go back to school the next day
like nothing happened that big ass
elephant no one wanted to acknowledge in
the room still present and accounted for
the kids knew what I what had happened I
knew what had happened yet no not one of
the adults wanted to talk about it
openly no one cared to ask me about the
trauma of the moment the fact that I hit
a girl with all when all my life I had
been told that was the one thing to
never ever do
after the accident I didn't associate
with the other kids in my class I only
wanted to get as far away from that
racial Madness as humanly possible
because it became evident these people
were incapable of being human
I never saw the girl again
maybe our parents took her out of school
unhappy at how white folks cared about
the fate of black boys in Jefferson
County
one thing I'm almost certain of and
would love to confirm years later
the little white girl never called
anyone a [ __ ] again
the next year sixth grade
I was strolling to an all-black Catholic
School planted directly in the hood
across the tracks in Titusville
thank God
there would be bonding over stack Hills
and platforms circular afros and braided
cornrows we drown each other in code
switching language the way we say Mane
and Gullah we didn't run from our own
skin as a matter of fact we ran into it
head first we were in a cocoon of
Blackness and whiteness had inverted to
the other
they were the others now
and we call each other [ __ ]
but it was love
learning early in life to take what is
given and turn it to something value
I'd love held and returned to a
mythological Paradise if only for a
moment
and yet society would not care about the
scars the racial wounds bandage up
but would expect me to forgive those who
know damn well
what they were doing
y'all still with me
[Applause]
let's see what we have here
and I think it's stopped right here
we're gonna snap uh let's do that
I read one poem for a girl how about
that we talked about
I heard someone was talking about the uh
the book situation so I have a poem um
in here called Roxbury Correctional book
club
basically it talks about the way we you
know we treat books on the inside and
all of these
um
I reference some kind of book
um their references incarcerations so
the first one is in poetry and I'm
thinking about um Robert Hayden
the second is Memoir Chester Hines
um the third one is fiction
um Mr Jackson residue years and the
fourth one is uh Miguel Pinero short
eyes right so here we go
now this is from 289 128 which was my
DLC number
um so I figured I would take it back and
claim license over that
289-128 property of the state Roxbury
Correctional book club one poetry
American Journal arrives in a library
card dog year to page 18 The Prisoner as
if the star here in media res dear
Hayden the eye and me no longer lives it
vanished I confess the collective we is
no longer better yes walls here are gray
not green but know your poems sing again
I does not exist comrade I do between
life and death in this Infinite Space
with no clock no markers of No Time
calendars to strike out the day or Days
running together after locking I write
the legal pad fills itself with regret
ownership is mine even in this cage a
Brokenness dictated by times torture
Ritz habeas corpuses motions denied in a
house lacking doorknobs return Yes the
Cockroach cult became a pet at Christmas
my silly snorted white lines to escape
physical torture of the Mind cascading
in and honestly stuff rapid then slow a
program of abstinence and Madness
two Memoir for old school
glove fist flashlight baton is fair
entering the hole requires protocol ears
mouth gums arms lift and reach bend over
Spirit each butt cheek Behold The Still
Holding cage that kills
a metal mirror both to the cinder block
old school stares at the refracted image
age and natural antagonists of the young
forgotten frown Brown face a little boy
once someone new well decades before
life before puby before adulthood
every two years hair turns gray a [ __ ]
Gone With No Redemption Song he would
never know if change is real
computer shop religion GED College
certificates Advocates a degree
non-change the quality of hurt
old school is in the frame struggling on
good days he reads Chester Hines
words corroborating Street heroics
however Define an adults of realism of
the slow fatality of imprisonment
the sun cannot bear witness anymore
forget wrote lethal injection a gunshot
fiction
have what the cigarette half lit a
bugler roll up outside walking the child
a fine missed pictures and Prime Evil
almost halfway until rain and close into
baptism moves for Sinners so believe in
uniform guards lining the walkway
the residue years alone from sale 2 came
last night the paperback version
bringing characters like Champ here
inside a Fool's dream or set up by
subtraction too many please illegal
searches guilty at the thought of life
though innocent as the Mary Shady
bureaucrats
dreaming family I draw wife kid dog in
my head time measures mathematics that
fail to reduce mandate to logic hidden
themselves disguises change the housing
unit is an American critique on full
display cloaked and numb silence
there are no empty skeletons on Wheels
with limbs pulled apart by team forces
the body is now instrument and tonight a
book might save my life after locking
drama
anything can be destroyed
for the Skeptics trust Donnie was
deflowered one night after count time
clearly the structure is obsolete says
Angela Davis and I sit in darkness
expected to write about Injustice a
witness to nothing on the stand but an
OP is I can be quite believable with the
unimaginable
a report from cell 23 irony or ironical
I say truth when plainly is a corrupted
condition identical to the blueprint
overlooked within the penal system you
can't see
the back drives Flashpoint a raging fire
this suicide must be I must commit to
killing the eye in order to save myself
there is no hope for the flower
under the voted metal door it appears
sometimes one act at a time
short eyes the dramatic play slid from
cold cement from sale to sale poet
Miguel Pinero is one of a few whoever
gave us prisoners us and I write
Society inverted imagine that concept
color two this violation is only
beginning of what you knew
come sit in the political Madness
alongside the bad
perception versus the real occurs quite
quick
or of course
crimes against Donnie occurred quite
frequently
all right
thank you
[Applause]
thank you I don't know how to follow
that
well I guess I start with an
introduction my name is Richard Rivera
I am
I'm the director of academic re-entry at
Cornell I also do ethnographic work in
Ithaca among the homeless population I'm
formally incarcerated
I served 39 years and I'm going to be
president of New York State obviously
um but um like this this
whole uh event has me thinking a lot
about prisons and um for Colt's name was
was this is working
yeah
a little closer like this close
yeah I should yeah all right so so so so
for Colt's name was brought up a lot
today
and um I think he's rightly so he's um
he's instrumental for us to understand
the disciplinary Technologies and
practices
that uh produce and reproduce uh the
subjectivities necessary for a Germanic
state but when I think of prison I think
it is more an encounter with the Absurd
so I think about Camus I think about
sought Heidegger cooking God
because that is what it is it's an alien
place where an individual is trying to
find themselves
uh places that they don't understand
friendships that they don't know how to
relate to and in a lot of cases this is
what happens in prison that struggle to
try to find yourself and Define yourself
in an environment that's really hostile
to you right and that's where our
literature and our and our creativity
comes from
is informed and defined by our
environment the scarcity of the
environment the violence of the
environment the way the the
prison life is structured as a
hierarchical uh environment in which the
individual with the greatest propensity
for violence generally rules
doesn't have to have an education money
or anything that doesn't matter in there
so they've invert it
hierarchy in prison where um yes where
those individuals are but there are
spaces that are created especially
uh for individuals in prison that are
trying uh to build their lives and one
of those is the classroom
I don't know if individuals that
teaching prison know how important the
space is for prisoners a college
classroom is a place where we go and we
can leave the institutional life behind
the prison life behind and where we
could perform as Scholars and and engage
in a way that we feel will not be
disciplined
and that is a tremendously incredible
space and and a lot of times in trying
to articulate our experience in prison
we sort of sort of
um
dress it in codes or or in scholarship
in order to get the word out and I think
a lot of times that what we get is a
filtered
fluffy kind of uh representation of what
prison life is like and I wanted to make
that point clear because
uh my own experience was was like that
was where I constantly struggled to try
to understand my place in the world who
I was and and that was detrimental and I
was able to
navigate my way through that with the
help of others and and some of the
literature that Brothers produced
um I want to there's this piece that was
produced by Yale uh doc Doolittle uh uh
called Zoe in which this individual uh
Ivan Kilgore who's a prisoner at um
I think California
and he writes about this experience
right he says allow me to introduce
myself
he says Within These Walls I am socially
I'm a socially dead person whose
existence has no legitimacy whatsoever
and this I think this this aptly
describes the state that most prisoners
find themselves in and why
um finding ways of expressing ourselves
through literature art poetry uh is so
essential to who we want to be and how
we want to Define ourselves he says this
reduction takes place in language and
culture typically beneath your conscious
awareness
like people we get our we get our
strings pulled by the forces and
circumstances they create meaning the
disciplinary state
uh they have no legitimacy whatsoever
which is to say no self-respect and no
sense of self-worth
right he goes on to say self-respect and
a sense of self-worth is the innermost
Armament of our soul
it lies at the heart of our attempts to
maintain humanness
to be deprived of it is to be
dehumanized to be cleaved from cast
below mankind dignity needless to say is
an essential as a center to human life
as water food and oxygen let me be clear
in prison degradation can be as little
as a bullet
and um and I have witnessed this I have
witnessed individuals be so beat down
be so dehumanized
I mean with these microaggressions and
macro aggressions because um there's a
lot of Beatdown in prison to oh women's
prison
where hygienic products are used as ways
to dehumanize women denied them
basic needs or making them beg for it or
manipulating in some way that a woman
feels less than and it's the same thing
with toilet paper um I went to uh Kathy
bodine's Memorial the other day and she
wrote a piece
a poem I wish I had it uh about toilet
paper
right and I myself witnessed this happen
uh this guy used to take a lot of crap
in prison take crafts with the prisoners
take crafts from the CEOs be deprived of
this that or the other and when they
were quiet on the company and he yells
out to the CEO I need some toilet paper
and the seal denies on the toilet paper
I'm not going to give it to you or
whatever and this guy just went on a
rampage he broke the sink he broke the
toilet they made out of ceramic he threw
his bed around he just snapped because
of that simple and and
denial was the last straw that's the
most he could take and um after that he
just kind of became like a wild person
but the but it's in the indignities uh
uh compounded that really make us
question our value and who we are and it
is only through art and literature
through writing to encounters with
people from higher educational programs
or people that treat us like human
beings that create these special spaces
for us that we ReDiscover our Humanity
it is this practice uh through Academia
that I believe leaves Brothers to
survive this environment because it is
prison is about resistance
and education and writing and and
literature is a form of resistance in
our way it's a way for us to express
ourselves to give voices to ourselves
even if it's fiction we always
incorporate a lot of ourselves in it
anybody who has taught in prison and has
received the essay from anyone knows
that a lot of that guy's personal life
is involved in that paper
and he talks from first-hand experience
because they want to be heard and spoken
to and um and I think that that is the
form of of disturbing the status quo
right what we do in prison through our
educational programs is it's a way of
disturbing this it's a way of this uh
gaining a little power where they have
none and a story of mine is uh I spent a
lot of time in the Box I don't know if
you could tell but I used to be like a
wild guy so I spent about 12 and a half
years in the box now in the boxes
punitive segregation
if imagine it like this so it's a place
where a jail within a jail I think
somebody described it earlier
the jail with an adult yes yes and um
and it is like that you go in there they
take everything from you
as soon as you go in they put you on the
wall make you face the wall and take
every piece of clothing and hand it back
then you bend over scoop over and do all
the indignities that they want
and they'll put you in a cell and
you got three things going on we got
three meals a day you got two showers a
week within 72 hours they're gonna let
you see your property to inventory and
they're going to give you a legal work
uh a pair of pants a pair of socks an
underwear a pair of slippers that sit 20
pictures and five books that's it
and these are the things that are in the
Box they use to control you
this is what they control they control
you with your meals they'll deny you
this my strategy
when I go to the box is that I don't
talk to anyone
I don't talk to the CEO I don't take the
food
I don't do any of that my go-to move was
going on hunger strikes
so they put me in a cell and I'll just
face the wall seals right there
and they'll come Mr Rivera Rivera you
want your food
the nurse wants to see you
do you want your property and this will
go on for 40 days
I'll go on like this for 40 days and you
think what the hell is this guy doing
there
and um
and that is a way
I think for me to gain power
and I'm gonna tell you how because in
the Box everything runs
repetitively like a mechanical thing the
seals make the rounds where they're
going to make the rounds they bring the
food when they're going to bring the
food the captain comes around once a
week or twice a week or something like
that
and during this period that I'm doing
this all this becomes Disturbed
seal starts announcing uh cell 16 is not
taking his food and he'll do this
repetitively the other prisoners start
hearing calling my name and I won't
answer
the captain will make more frequent
rounds the chaplain will end up there
the debt of Security will end up there
about 20 days into the pro into this
protest one CEO will come and say you I
don't know why you're doing that but I
respect you you know
because I I drink water and I don't eat
and um by the time I finish 40 days I
have to stop because they got a standing
order to force feed you in 40 days in
New York state
and um last time I lost 68 pounds doing
this
but by the time I finish
um
they don't mess with my showers
they don't mess with my food they give
me the property they're like they're
supposed to give me they don't
disrespect prisoners next to me I sort
of created a space I have Disturbed the
power dynamics in that place I have
gained a little power but it's obviously
none and a system of Total Domination I
think James Scott wrote a book called an
essay called the weapons of the week he
doesn't mention the hunger strike but
Bobby Sands and dumb brothers and iron
did and that's where I got the idea from
and these are the little forms of
resistance that we could use sort of to
disturb it and writing is one of them
that was just a physical uh antidote
about how how power is Disturbed
providing poetry is one of them speaking
asserting yourself giving yourself a
voice or finding the medium for your
voice is a really powerful uh I think
tool to have in prison I think higher
educational programs in prison
I do this and then we talk about the
subject of this booster I want to bring
it around the subject of this um
of this uh Symposium imagination and
incarceration when I heard that like you
I was struck by the singular of mine was
it you somebody else mentioned a single
of mine and um
and I thought about how come no one is
speaking about what informs the
prisoner's imagination
right and I think it is important to
understand that the prisoner's
imagination is informed by their
environment of course by the cultural
norms that are developed in there by the
economy by the systems of what I call
prison life the environment in the yard
where prisoners are making things happen
in an environment that's defined by
scarcity
and violence so they'll have nine way
courts and 1 100 prisoners that want to
work out
and prisoners will fight for those
courts uh they'll have only Services
only 40 people allow in the room as
services so the other Christians or
Muslims who have to weigh some grass so
where else only 10 percent of the
population is what is prison Rich that
means that they get regular packages and
food and support from family and they
sort of become victims in a lot of sense
or have to participate in the black
market in some way because this is the
way the system is
um
and um but this informs us so again in
the box right in the Box uh we have 43
cells on the company
they got solid doors
and I have a cigarette in one cell
and this guy will have matches in 23
cells there's no Porters out there's
nothing happening so what do we do we um
we take the toothpaste
and we'll break it in half put wet
toilet paper in there take our
underwears take the strings out
tied to the thing and slide it under the
door real fast and it'll travel like 15
20 cells and the guy will do the same
thing over there and it'll happen fixing
a hot pot with a nail clipper I mean the
Ingenuity and creativeness that this
environment produces
uh I think works its way into the way we
express ourselves creatively Expresses
in our writing in our codes that we
switch so in a writer writes from prison
he's actually speaking to two audiences
he's speaking to you in a way that you
will understand but I know what he means
when he uses coded language there's a
difference there and um and that got me
taken because of this but it also got me
thinking because the further I've moved
away from prison The more I've been
thinking about it
and um to end I want to read a piece
from Dwayne Betts I want to honor the
Wayne Betts he's my boy
and he writes a PCR code confession
which I think speaks
to that
getting closer to prison As you move
further away and I think it's important
all right so it goes um
I'm gonna mess it up because I know I
mess up so you don't report it back to
him I'm gonna tell him I can give him a
text
I got him on speed though
how often I thought of prison she would
walk out
you walk out the door that leaves just
as much to Madness as any home we desire
she will walk out and never return my
employers will call me a liar and fire
me my dreams are not all nightmares but
this history has turned my mind's
landscape into a Dragoon
uh I do not sing have lied for so many
months now that truth hurt Bringers lost
sleeping beside her when my men when my
memory is holding me tight as she did
before the lies turned everything into a
battle I once gas and launch and try to
strangle the pillow she placed beneath
my head imagine me explaining that to
her while still shivering with a panic
and broken man like a panic and broken
man I stopped believing in God long
before then but that night I went
outside there was no light but Darkness
I saw something of what
of what inedible is touch me my children
slept with their lights on I walked into
this still lit room my son was asleep
and his brother
draped over his body as if he were a
pillow the way he loved his brother was
everything my time and the cell denied
me if I told my woman that she would
want to know
if I thought I deserve all that loss a
mother wonders why I won't let it go and
hold on to the happiness and the life we
have
but how do I explain that I'll sign on
nights like this is where I first
learned just how violent I might be
that I think of prison because in all
DCS I still cannot pronounce the name of
my victim
done good um
I'm Gonna Give You Kudos five stars
[Applause]
definitely gonna let me know
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you